in a place that once teemed with
tourists we find a small band of Rangers
and a dog called Scarlett trying to keep
the wildlife alive for the future of
this South African game park is in the
balance the pandemic has chased off the
visitors and the poachers had stomachs
to fill one truck with a handful of men
who've got 20,000 hectares at the Dino
Kane Game Reserve to patrol and in
recent weeks they've had very little
peace can you stop the poachers
intruders have laced the park's northern
boundary with metal snares and an animal
has walked into their trap a fully grown
male Impala has been snagged by a snare
and the team from Dino king are trying
to release it he must have been standing
here for hours he would have died of
starvation or exhaustion eventually the
poachers would have slaughtered the
animal from meat and there's no shortage
of customers after 9 weeks of lockdown
millions of South Africans are hungry
the head of the anti poaching unit began
to comb the area for other snares these
tree trunks and branches were rung with
wire a few hours before our arrival this
area is being covered in snares there
may be 10 there may be more than 10 and
it's going to take the team a while to
to get rid of them all but the poachers
they could put them back tonight this is
really quite period for you
you know if it keeps on for a long time
you can work out for a short time but if
it's going to go on for six months then
we'll run into serious trouble serious
trouble
that's what park manager David Boshoff
is dealing with the committed
conservationist now scrambling from
money to keep the facility afloat so the
whole you comes into the gemenese of
shut down because it was not even one
tourist in this park for the Floyd
problem without ticket sales he can't
pay the staff and the park can't
function without Panama's lost this week
we lost a water buck
we lost impala and we lost a line a
month ago in Red Lion was actually he
walked into a snake that was a that was
it for a for over Angela
the Rangers that they know where the
poachers entered the park the night
before and took us to a spot where the
electrified fence meets an impoverished
township of a hundred thousand people
heat sensitive cameras often pick up the
intruders but it's much more difficult
to catch them in the act if you see he
is one of his buttons that he lost as he
crawled through the community on the
fence line is called Hammonds crowd and
the lockdown has hit the residents hard
they turned up with wheelbarrows when
the park distributed parcels of rice and
beans but the government hasn't offered
them the Dino King reserve is in a
precarious position it's taken loans and
donations but it needs the tourists to
return for the animals and the game park
are now endangered John Sparkes Sky News
in Hammonds crowd